thanks to deep sentinel for keeping
legal eagles safe and sound get 15
off the only security system that stops
crime before it happens with a link
below
so let's move on to something that is a
little bit more fun than lighthearted
[Music]
murder
welcome back to laws broken where an
attorney destroys your favorite movies
by showing you how illegal everything is
because everything is illegal who
doesn't love indiana jones the story of
a swashbuckling hero professor who
saves the world from nazi megalomania
and wins the heart of his fair maiden
yes i'm talking about 1981's box office
smash indiana jones and the raiders of
the lost ark you probably remember this
as wholesome family entertainment where
a professor who happens to be good with
a whip
saves the world from the worst villains
on the planet
nazis the movie seems to have it all
indiana jones outwitting bad guys and
sporting a cool hat an arrogant french
baddie who gets his comeuppance and a
spirited heroine who falls in love with
the man who saves her life
well i hate to break it to you but
indiana jones isn't
exactly a humble archaeologist this is a
movie where the hero travels the world
looting graves and temples stealing
artifacts and permanently destroying
precious historical sites you know kind
of like the taliban he admits to
serious crimes against the woman that
he's supposed to be in love with and the
movie also has an absurdly high
body count and despite all of the
property destruction grave robbing
murder kidnapping
and rape this movie inspired several
disney park attractions
so come for a crazy ride with me as we
discover the dark side
of indiana jones and all the laws broke
it
you guys ever go to sunday school so
let's start with the grave robbing if
you thought it didn't seem right that
indiana jones was stealing precious
artifacts and bringing them home to the
united states
and pillaging the hovitos well you might
be right
indiana jones is an archaeologist who
purports to save things to put them in a
museum but
is he allowed to steal artifacts from
foreign countries and graves to fill the
chicago museum
no yes well maybe jones may say he wants
rare artifacts to be placed in a museum
but later in his apartment we see a
number of artifacts that he probably
didn't buy from home goods so what's the
real story on people who find buy and
sell artifacts
well treasure hunters antique dealers
and even museums get busted all the time
for selling or transferring or
transporting stolen artifacts and now
for the part you've been waiting for
is indiana jones a grave robbing
profiteer well antiques trading can be
perfectly legal or
totally illegal depending on where the
artifacts are found and how they are
sold
as long as the person follows the laws
of the country of origin regarding
excavation transport and sale of
archaeological
artifacts the trade is generally legal
however there's also a
billion dollar black market for ancient
antique objects
there's no one international law that
all nations must follow instead
artifacts are protected by treaties like
the hague convention for the protection
of cultural property in the event of
armed conflict this is a treaty ratified
by 132 countries that protects cultural
property during wars and armed conflicts
there's also the rome statute
establishing the international criminal
court which makes it a war crime to
deliberately target religious
educational artistic
or scientific properties for destruction
or defacement the unesco convention on
the means of prohibiting and preventing
the illicit import export and transfer
of ownership of cultural property
is meant to stop the circulation of
stolen items and this convention gives
member nations the right to recover
stolen or illegally exported antiquities
from
member countries currently 140 countries
are parties to this convention
including egypt nepal greece and all of
the south american countries that
indiana jones may have visited the
united states ratified the unesco
convention and implemented it with the
convention on cultural property
implementation actor cipa
sipa applies if the objects are actually
cultural artifacts or they are stolen or
exported
sipa includes a safe harbor provision
that allows for the import of cultural
artifacts
to the united states if the importer can
provide an export certificate
from the foreign country and the safe
harbor provision also applies if the
importer can produce satisfactory
evidence that the material was either
exported prior to the date the import
restrictions were published in the
federal register
or exported from the foreign country at
least 10 years prior to the date of
entry into the united states
now i can hear the internet comments
already there was no cipa when indiana
jones
museum did the stuff from the south
american temple but it's worth noting
that this movie is set in the 1930s
which was kind of a big news decade in
case you were wondering and haven't
opened a history book the nazis really
did loot and plunder priceless works of
art antique objects and property of
people they murdered and these events
actually were the impetus for the
international treaties that would one
day stop indiana jones from taking home
souvenirs
from his archaeological digs or at least
force him to produce a permit or
satisfactory
evidence showing that he came by the
objects legally lawyers
always making people do more paperwork
in america there is another important
law in this particular case the national
stolen property actor nspa
which makes it a felony to knowingly
possess conceal sell or dispose of any
goods of the value of
five thousand dollars or more which have
crossed a state or u.s boundary
after being stolen the federal
government is more likely to use this
law than cepa when someone makes a claim
that
an american illegally acquired foreign
antiquities and under the nspa the word
stolen takes on a different meaning than
what we're used to in general parlance
generally when something is removed from
a person or a business or institution
that's theft but under the nspa an
object doesn't have to be
actually taken from a person or business
stolen can also mean removed from an
abandoned place like a temple or a grave
or historical site that nobody
officially owns
so it's illegal under the nspa to take
something from a foreign country without
explicit permission
from its current government or taking
something with permission of a colonial
or occupying force rather than from the
country's current
legitimate government so indiana jones
could try to defend his theft by arguing
that nobody actually owned the golden
idol
however the nspa also applies when a
government simply declares an artifact
stolen this is usually enough
in situations where it seems like no one
actually owns the artifact in question
and when jones took the golden idol away
from a temple in the deep jungle of
south america let's just say it was from
brazil
it was only a crime if brazil had passed
a law or otherwise declared it a
state-owned cultural object if a foreign
government doesn't make an ownership
declaration then some american courts
reasoned that prosecuting people in the
u.s for
illegally exporting artifacts from
foreign nations would simply amount to
the united states enforcing the other
nation's laws for them
now indiana jones isn't the only one
engaging in some suspicious activity
here there's also the treachery of
belloc but stealing the idol from dr
jones in the first place brings up
another question could bellock get in
trouble for stealing the golden idol
from
indy dr jones again we see there is
nothing you can possess which i cannot
take away
well in most jurisdictions if a person
accepts possession of goods or property
and knew that they were stolen
this is a crime we don't want people uh
claiming that they didn't know the thing
was stolen in the first place and just
getting away with selling clearly stolen
property and for the sake of this
exploration let's assume that bellock
sets up a shop in the u.s with the idol
that he took from dr jones in the united
states receipt of stolen property is a
federal crime under 18 usc
2315 defined as knowingly receiving
concealing or disposing of stolen
property with a value of at least five
thousand dollars that
also constitutes interstate commerce if
bellock intended to move the idol across
state lines he could be prosecuted for
receipt of possession of stolen
property he'd also be subject to
prosecution under the nspa
of course receiving and selling stolen
property is usually a state law crime so
bellock would certainly be
guilty of all of the state law crimes as
well i'm a shadowy reflection of you
don't take only a nudge to make you like
me
to push you out of the light and anyone
who received the idol from belloc would
also be guilty as law students learn
from their property and criminal law
courses
a thief can't pass good title to stolen
objects
and a stolen object retains its stolen
status forever no matter when the thief
happens to have taken the object or how
many different people held onto that
object
this actually happens with some
frequency in the art world and for all
of you budding art collectors out there
and object status is stolen
also doesn't change if someone buys it
in good faith down the line without
knowledge that it was stolen
many owners ago many disappointed art
collectors and museums have been forced
to return
objects that they thought they had
purchased from a reputable source
hobby lobby recently had to return
thousands of
middle eastern artifacts because they
had been
wrongfully acquired this is why jones
ultimate motive for removing the items
doesn't really matter
so jones went to south america and
entered the sanctuary of a temple and
removed the golden idol did he have a
permit for that expedition
it doesn't look like it and that means
he didn't have the permission of whoever
owned the site or whatever government is
in power and although this particular
expedition probably
isn't a war crime it's still serious
enough that jones is guilty of violating
the unesco convention as well as cipa
he's also in big trouble for removing
objects from all over the world and
bringing them back to the u.s
even if some of the sites were abandoned
like the sanctuary and the opening
sequence probably doesn't matter and
jones could expect to be prosecuted
as a repeat offender under the nspa and
although jones steals the arc
of the covenant it's unclear whether the
us government would prosecute him for
the theft under cipa or the nspa
but i have been informed that the us
government has top men
working on this investigation top
men top men so that's your general
history lesson now let's move on to
interpersonal communications
generally in american cinema we don't
like our protagonists engaging in
questionable sexual behavior
we're not the french but here's a scene
you probably don't remember seeing the
first time around recall that
jones has an affair with marion
ravenwood his professor's daughter
seems normal i learned to hate you in
the last 10 years
i never meant to hurt you i was a child
i was in love
it was wrong and you knew it yikes i did
what i did you don't have to be happy
about it but maybe we could help each
other out now
double yikes did indiana jones just
admit to the fact of statutory rape then
say he was tired of saying sorry then he
needed a 3 000
gold medallion well here's the context
and i'm not sure that that actually
makes it any better the raiders of the
lost ark screenplay was pretty clear
about marion's age it says she was about
25 years old when the movie begins
marion was the daughter of jones's
mentor abner ravenwood
jones said he hadn't spoken to marion
for 10 years which means that
10 years ago they had a relationship
here's the problem if marion was 25
during the film
then she was with jones 10 years earlier
when she was just 15 years old
and since that description is off screen
we could maybe guesstimate that
lucas spielberg and screenwriter
lawrence kasdan were not thinking that
precisely about marion's age and
hadn't gone to all the trouble of
subtracting 10 from
25 and getting 15. but we would probably
be wrong
a few years ago a transcript of a
discussion between lucas spielberg and
kazan
made the rounds the three men talked
about marion's age and her involvement
with jones they decided that she had to
be
under the age of 16 when she was with
jones so yes they knew
what they were doing and on screen
marion says she was a child and jones
doesn't deny
that it happened he even tells her that
she needs to get over it
i did what i did you don't have to be
happy about it but maybe we could help
each other out now
hashtag me too now this is not a
laughing matter statutory rape is a
crime that involves sexual contact with
a person who is under the age specified
by law commonly referred to as the age
of consent the age of consent differs
from state to state and so does the name
of the crime and most states no longer
refer to this crime as statutory rape
instead using terms such as sexual
intercourse with a minor
sexual assault of a child or criminal
sexual penetration of a minor child
under a certain age now statutory rape
in general is based on the notion that a
person
under a certain age cannot consent to
sexual contact or activity because he or
she lacks the maturity or judgment
necessary to make
a knowing choice about sexual activity
and statutory rape is one of the rare
strict liability criminal offenses out
there that means that the mental state
of
the offender isn't really relevant if
the sexual contact happened
the defendant has no defense because the
victim is deemed too young to have been
capable of consenting that means that
even if the defendant honestly and
reasonably believe that the minor was
old enough to give legal consent
they are still guilty of the offense and
that's not even the situation we have in
this film here indiana jones was
mentored by marion's father and he
knew her when she was growing up he
agrees that yes
he had a relationship with her when she
was a minor and
knew it i never meant to hurt you it was
wrong and you knew it
and for jurisdictional purposes let's
assume that this happened in illinois
where jones was living when he was at
the university of chicago if marion was
15 at the time she was with indy then he
would be in big trouble regardless of
whether
she was in love or he thought she could
consent and jones could also be
prosecuted for aggravated criminal
sexual abuse because he was in a
position of trust authority or
supervision over marion
remember he was a teaching assistant to
her father and may be considered someone
who was in a position of trust
so the conclusion is that jones is
guilty of second-degree sexual assault
because she was 15 years old when he had
a relationship with her and he was more
than five years older than she was
indiana jones doesn't really have a
defense and can expect a minimum jail
term
of three to seven years in prison a fine
of up to 25 000
or both he'd also have to register as a
sex offender so how are we feeling about
the good old days of family friendly
entertainment now
yikes so let's move on to something that
is a little bit more fun than
lighthearted
murder you may recall that indiana jones
is being chased through the streets of
cairo by a bunch of goons when he hits a
dead end and there he finds a man with a
sword after the man
impressively demonstrates how he would
cut jones up indiana jones pulls out a
gun and shoots the man
dead this scene was not brought to you
by smith and wesson the original scene
was supposed to be an epic sword fight
that would take three days to film but
at the time
ford kept running into a stomach bug he
asked steven spielberg if he could just
quote
shoot the son of a indiana jones brought
to you
by dysentery but what about his foe
in this movie was jones justified in
shooting this man was it murder or
could he shoot this sob in self-defense
well american law generally has
different rules for the use of deadly
force in self-defense than
use of non-deadly force in self-defense
and generally you can use non-deadly
force to defend yourself against
any unlawful attack and also to defend
your property against theft or unlawful
damage
now it varies slightly state by state
but when you're defending yourself
from non-deadly force you can only use
the amount of force necessary to fend
off the attacker
and you should also probably retreat if
possible now traditionally you could use
deadly force to defend yourself
only if you were being threatened with
death serious bodily injury rape or
kidnapping
so imagine that someone takes a swing at
you outside of a bar they miss
but they're mad and you know it what can
you do you can meet their violence only
with the amount of force necessary to
fend off the attacker therefore you can
punch the person to prevent them from
hitting you but you can't pull out a gun
and shoot the puncher because in this
hypothetical you didn't reasonably fear
for your life just because someone
wanted to fight you you could
also leave the scene and flee entirely
however things get more complicated when
the person threatening you
is brandishing objects that could
inflict more damage than a fist
can you shoot someone for brandishing a
sword during the 1930s when this movie
took place
if you were outside of your home and
were approached by an aggressor
you could only use deadly force if
someone attacked you with deadly force a
famous treatise on criminal law states
that quote
merely to threaten death or serious
bodily harm without any intention to
carry out the threat
is not to use deadly force so that one
may be justified in
pointing a gun at his attacker when he
would not be justified
pulling the trigger following these
principles a guy could brandish that
sword without triggering jones right to
use deadly force
and many state courts have held that a
defendant's mere display of a knife
during a fight
while implying the threat of violence
does not constitute deadly force the
prosecution would argue that jones just
stood there which shows that there was
plenty of time for him to run or even
walk away but
indiana jones lawyers would obviously
say that there was nowhere for him to
run since he had already been attacked
by people in the market and was
surrounded by bad guys
in modern law there's a trend to give
people greater rights to use deadly
force
because america but many state laws say
that a person must have a reasonable
belief of imminent death or
injury and the inability to retreat in
safety
in order to use lethal force and then
they're the so-called stand-your-ground
laws which give people the right to use
deadly force in any place where they
have a legal right to be
as long as they reasonably feared
serious bodily harm or death they don't
have the duty to retreat
u.s states are pretty evenly split
between stand your ground laws and duty
to retreat laws
now it's possible that indiana jones
would have a good case for self-defense
under these modern flexible deadly force
laws but the biggest problem is that
jones doesn't even try to get away
indiana jones would have to prove that
he's in distress and fear of his life
and he has no choice but to shoot his
way out of a jam however that's a hard
argument to make when he's
literally just standing there looking
pretty relaxed given the situation and
there's also a lot of witnesses who
don't exactly
look like they'd be favorable to his
defense so the conclusion here is that
jones is probably guilty of some variety
of murder here since
this wasn't a premeditated crime he
could be convicted of second-degree
murder which is typically defined as a
murder that is not premeditated or
murdered that is caused by the
offender's reckless conduct that
displays an obvious lack of concern for
human life
the penalty for second-degree murder in
most jurisdictions is about 10 years to
life
now before we tally up all the crimes
against indiana jones and see how long
he's going to jail
let's talk about the dishonorable
mentions of all the other crimes that
were committed
indiana jones is not the only one who's
up to no good in this movie and the
cartoonish violence
includes a lot of carnage there are of
course lots of bad guy crimes by people
who work for the nazis in nepal they
burned down marion's bar during a
gunfight that they started this is arson
they're also guilty of murder and
attempted murder
many times over the baddies did a lot of
criming during the market scene in
egypt look at all the unprovoked battery
offenses with punches and various
weapons
and again attempted murders here they're
kidnapping marion inside of a basket
you can't do this to me i'm an american
and here indy avoids just being stabbed
this was an attempted murder since the
guy had a long knife and wanted to kill
dr jones
under us law when indy moves away at the
last second and the guy stabs someone
else to death by accident
he can still be charged with felony
murder indiana jones pushing and shoving
people and opening their baskets
forcefully constitutes assault and
battery and trespassed
shadows and of course there's no
exception because he's looking for
marion some random beggars
robbed indiana jones while he was hiding
around the corner indiana jones shoots
up a vehicle he thinks marion is in
it catches fire and everybody dies
whoopsie whoopsie
bear-chested nazi commits some very
poorly choreographed batteries against
indiana jones and then dies in a way
that might be negligent homicide while
driving a truck indiana jones takes out
some bedouins building a house on the
side of the road at the very least
negligent homicide during the chase
scene jones has to throw a lot of guys
off a truck let's declare this
self-defense so take one away a german
u-boat intercepts indiana jones's boat
to steal back the ark and kidnap marion
now luckily for you i'm not going to go
off the deep end about maritime law
but boarding a foreign-flagged vessel
constitutes interference with the normal
freedom of navigation and lawful passage
in accordance with the law of the sea
and finally this monkey sells out marion
to the bad guys clearly committing a
conspiracy to kidnap marian
but monkeys can't be convicted of crimes
then of course there's bellock who gets
his hands very dirty
who is but a shadowy reflection of
indiana jones who commits
multiple crimes against marion including
kidnapping false imprisonment assault
battery and
threatened with attempted rape for
statutory rape he's probably looking
at at least three years in prison
bellock locks jones in a tomb this is
both false imprisonment and kidnapping
and bellock tries to kill jones at least
10 times in this movie
which is 10 counts of either attempted
murder or conspiracy to commit murder
just because
he's not getting his hands actually
dirty with the murder itself
doesn't absolve him of these crimes and
of course many of these attempted
murders are clearly premeditated which
would mean
premeditated first-degree murder bellock
is also guilty of the same antiquities
violations as dr jones and
not for nothing bellock did try to
commit genocide against the entire
planet by arming the nazis with the ark
of the covenant but now let's tally up
the crimes against
dr henry jones jr aka
indiana jones
for the antiquities violations jones is
likely to get at least one year in
prison for violating the nsps a ten
thousand dollar fine and of course
returning all of the artifacts that he
stole
back to their original country of origin
for statutory rape he's probably looking
at at least three years in prison for
all of the murders that indiana jones
committed
assuming that self-defense does not
apply and that's probably a coin flip
depending on the jurisdiction he'd
probably get about 10 years in jail for
the guy with a sword
50 years in jail for the people killed
when he blew up the truck and about 20
years in jail for negligent homicide
when he drove the truck into some people
on the side of the road
for a total of about 84 years in prison
dr indiana jones
you belong in a museum that belongs in a
museum
and by museum i mean jail
but the thing is if indiana jones comes
for your artifacts you'd better have a
good security system to stop him
and deep sentinel is just that while
most security systems would simply
record indeed breaking into your home or
stealing your packages
deep sentinel would actually stop it
because it's the only security system
that has a real human guard
watching your cameras in real time i
actually use deep sensitive for my own
house because it's not like other
security systems
their cameras have a two-way speaker
built in so when they detect an intruder
or a package thief
they actively intervene and either scare
the intruder away or
call the police because a better way to
solve crime is to stop it before it
happens
i used to live in a house with a
traditional security system with one of
those stupid keypads where the alarm
would go off if you didn't enter your
code in time and i actually got fined
hundreds of dollars when the police were
called out on a false alarm but deep
sentinel is different deep sentinel is
the only security company that actually
monitors your property in real time
and will actually intervene before
something happens when the camera
detects a visitor
the guards log into your system and
assess the situation then the loud
two-way speaker lets deep sentinel
guards intervene and stop crime before
it happens
they can ask the visitor questions or
tell them that the police are on their
way
it's absolutely genius and they've done
this for me many times their guards have
even called me to summarize what's going
on in front of my house and let me know
that they're actively watching the
situation
it's the kind of dynamic response that
only a human can provide and deep
sentinel responds in seconds when
traditional alarm systems would take
half an hour if they responded at all
and smart cameras which are actually
pretty dumb will
just give you a video of what happened
after the fact because deep sentinel
uses real humans there are virtually no
false alarms and i haven't had a single
package stolen since i've installed
deep sentinel and of course deep
sentinel is wi-fi and app enabled so i
can pull out my phone
and check on my front porch or backyard
with one click anywhere in the world and
i can turn on the two-way radio and i
can talk to delivery people or guests
myself and the system even automatically
tells me when packages
are delivered so if you'd like to try
the only security system that has real
human guards
legal eagles will get 15 off when you go
to deepsentinel.com
legal eagle or use the promo code legal
eagle at checkout
but this is a special deal that will
expire in a few days and only if you use
the link below so get 15
off of deep sentinel when you go to
deepsential.com legaleagle or use the
link
in the description plus clicking on that
link really helps out this channel
so do you agree with my verdict for
indeed should indy go to jail for
longer leave your objections in the
comments and check out this playlist
over here with all of my other laws
broken videos like
home alone and willy wonka it's all
there so just click on this playlist and
i'll see you
in court